very quickly just going back to legally
blonde there was a thing uh last year
you must when it hit the headlines uh
president trump he made
the uh commencement speech oh yeah yeah
and then it turned out it for quite a
strong resemblance
to elle's graduation speech
[Music]
yeah yeah it did yeah was it
was it jimmy fallon who found this out i
know it was all over the internet no it
was yeah maybe it was on jimmy's show
if you haven't seen it it's sort of
unbelievable we'll just show them the
the thing that we take our next steps
into the world
you must go forth into the world it is
with passion
passion courage of conviction courage in
your convictions
and strong sense of self be true to
yourself
we did it i did it
[Applause]
have you not seen that
[Music]
i've never seen that i always fall down
youtube rabbit holes and i miss that
completely
he's truly he is better when he sticks
to the script
[Applause]
do you know how that happened he's just
a fan of the film
sure he's just a big fan very bizarre
when was it it written or how was it
planned because it seems
so kind of perfectly placed now it's
very kind of zeitgeist
in that kind of trumpian america john
lithgow's character is
almost a version of trump exactly and
was that all planned
no the scary part is that there's so
many like him
yes we were thinking about the dentist
that killed the lion
yes and um so it was before
trump but when we were shooting he was
campaigning
but now i won't ask you about your
political opinions but uh we do have a
picture
that suggests but you're not going to
ask me because because you're
you already know here you are with a
lovely
this is the pinata style you know
the minute he started talking about the
mexican two days later we were selling
pinatas
tomorrow somebody brought one to a party
at my house
the mexicans lined up worse than the
little kids
and the tragic thing was that the first
person that went on it
killed it in two seconds nobody else got
to hit the pinata
but some people were stepping on it on
the floor
have you met the real donald trump oh
yeah what was he like
strange
it's like i mean one thing you gotta
give it to him like
he is what it is he's not like yes he's
not pretending he's pretending
yeah what you see is what you get
unfortunately oh my god
cause david now you haven't met him have
you no i have not but you did you did
take the opportunity of dressing up as
him
[Applause]
yeah that was halloween
and it was uh you know my halloween
costume was before he was the president
and i thought well
you know what's the sort of biggest
nightmarish figure
in today's culture and i thought donald
trump not for a moment did we think he
would actually become president no you
must have thought i'll do it this year
because next year
it will be old yeah how long did it take
to wash that off afterwards just
out of interest because that is quite
the amount of it was three or four weeks
and well because this week donald
trump's been on his first trip abroad
as as president so here's some pictures
of him
here he is in saudi arabia now oh my god
that was going on there well apparently
it's some sort of peace thing but it
doesn't look like a crystal ball doesn't
it
i see impeachment i see disgrace
a mystic
he then went to jerusalem where he
visited the western wall
and he placed a note inside presumably
the note was for the wall builders
call me i've got a job
but you look at this picture you've got
he can't even touch a wall appropriately
look at that it says it looks so wrong
it does look sleazy for some reason
by the way if anyone's wondering what
that unusual thing on his head is that's
his hair
this is my favorite picture from the
trip i'm sure you've seen it on
wednesday
uh trump met the vote now
that is a man thinking take the
picture
looks like she's at a funeral i mean she
wishes
there's a weird thing going on at the
moment
well so many weird things because of
donald trump but
we're suddenly hearing about all these
famous
people that he asked out and you are
one of them
i know you could be the first lady
i could have changed the course of
history
no i was we were doing primary colors
which was a film about the
about the clintons and about that that
it was at universal it was 97 so
a long time ago so actually one
only associated senior trump with
tasteless architecture at that point
um and well it's still a boundless sense
of narcissistic kind of
madness but i was in my little trailer
which was a normal trailer
and it had a phone like a proper phone
with a you know landline
sort of trailer though so it's kind of
yeah and i'd no one had ever run me on
it nor had i ever used it in fact i
assumed it was not a working machine and
it rang one day and i picked it up and
uh it was donald trump donald trump what
donald trump
donald trump was on the other end of the
phone going
hi it's donald trump here and i thought
someone was having a laugh
i said oh [__] off
and he said no i'm ringing to um ask you
if you would like to you know
um come and stay in one of my lovely
apartments and
maybe we could have dinner and um and i
just didn't know what to say i was just
absolutely astounded because how did you
get my
number i mean a number that i didn't
have
in the trailer yeah and so i just said
i'd get back to him
i'm in so many ways i wish i had because
if i had gone out with him for dinner
i could have done that
and then we would all have known
slightly surprised that pierce morgan's
doing it because he i don't know if you
know
he's a big donald trump supporter and i
know you're not a fan i'm really not
i'm really not no i am i am reminded of
a time
um about five years ago i was at a
dinner
with my ex-wife brooke and her family
and this and that and about halfway
through
i i i noticed um donald
um staring at my watch
and so he started saying you know listen
uh i'm i'm sorry that i wasn't invited
to your wedding this and that
i'm sorry i can't make your wedding and
i think i didn't invite you um
so so he says but you know i want to
give you a uh an early wedding gift
as a gesture for me and melania and she
doesn't say a word she's very sweet and
very pretty but just kind of sits there
you know yeah uh anywho so uh
so he says these are these are platinum
diamond harry winston
and he pulls off his cufflinks and he
gives them to me
and so i'm like oh gosh uh mr trump you
you really shouldn't do this because no
no it's the least i can do and you know
have a great marriage and all that
little did he know um so
so so smash cut to about
six months later i had a uh some jewelry
getting appraised at the house you know
and and and she finished and was leaving
and
and i said oh yeah you know there's
there's another a couple of pieces that
i have that i'm that i'm very
curious about could would you mind
appraising these she said no
what are they i said well you know i
explained the dinner and this and that
these are from donald trump
harry winston you know flawless dees
platinum
she she took the loop uh spent about
four seconds and and kind of recoiled
from it uh
much like people do from trump and um so
so she says uh in in in their finest
moment this is cheap pewter and and
and bad zirconias and they're stamped
trump
and i just thought i just thought what
does this really say
about the man you know um that he said
here's like a great
wedding gift and it's just it's just a
bag of dog [__] you know
now is it is it is that the laughter i
can hear
coming from across the pond at our
country about this charlatan
it's quite listen there's it's scary
times all over the place
good and decent people will make the
right choice and the circus will leave
town before it uh contaminates
the oval office
you went to the inauguration and that
was because you were first lady not
because you've been nominee right and
and you know i really tried to get out
of going um
i you know because i was going not as
the uh
candidate or the opponent but as a
former first lady because the tradition
is presidents and former first ladies
all show up regardless of republican or
democrat to show support
continuity of our government so you know
we
we thought okay maybe others aren't
going so you know we
we called
we called the bushes and the elder
bushes were in the hospital which i
think was legitimate
and so then you know we called the
younger bushes and they said yeah we're
going we called the carters they said
yeah we're going so
you know bill and i looked at each other
and said well we gotta go
oh my gosh i i just i try to describe in
the book
what that felt like because i didn't
know what to expect what i wanted
to have happen was despite the kind of
campaign he ran
i wanted him to rise the occasion of
being our president and being the
president for everybody not just people
who supported him
that didn't happen and so we were we
were sitting there
and we were listening i was sitting next
to george w
bush and bill was on my other side and
we were listening this really dark
divisive speech that i describe as a
cry from the white nationalist gut
and i was so disappointed uh really
so uh so sad that it wasn't
an outreach it was a narrowing and a
hammering of
uh what he had said before and it's
reported so i put it in the book
it's reported that george w bush at as
it ends says that was some weird [__]
and it wasn't the fellas where they had
the real uh kind of gangsters on set
well there were people around who you
know
stole cameras you know they're the same
with casino
and stuff that's you know that's part of
it
and does that help or does it make you a
bit nervous no no everybody you know
people like to be in movies and part of
them
and uh the guys in that world
as much if not more than most people
yeah and
and you talk about that world what is it
about movies in that world because
almost since
they started making movies they've been
telling stories about
gangsters and mafia and mobsters and now
here we are in 2019
and this is still a big deal what is the
appeal of those characters i don't know
i guess it's because they defy the law
in some way and they still and they have
their own laws their own
there's there's more of an honor uh like
especially in the godfather i think
especially at that time in the late uh
60s the godfather with the government
and everything the vietnam war i think
that the
the idea that this culture had more
there was more respect and more more
structure
uh and more right and wrong
uh than we were seeing in in the war and
with
our leaders and not being told the truth
about what was really going on
and i think um so that that's why
was a part of its appeal yeah today we
have a kind of
a weird twisted president
who thinks he's a gangster uh who's a
not not even a good gangster
because this is a guy that you know even
gangsters like honor among thieves
you shake a hand you have your word
that's all you have
is your word and they have your word and
that's it
this guy is not the case
i didn't even bring him up ladies
because i heard you talking on a show
where you met
donald trump yes but not particularly
because you wanted to
no i was i was i just i love real estate
i have to go you
no i was like i was i was um like 11 or
12 and
i was going it was when we were doing
press for the first potter movie and
they took us to new york and it was the
first time doing sort of the morning
shows in new york
and i was about to go on the today show
i've never been on sort of american sort
of morning tv before and i was quite
nervous
and uh donald trump was also had also
been on that day and so that
that's donald trump for those of you who
have blissfully forgotten what he looked
like
but he um then they sort of walked me
over to him because clearly they were
like
you know somebody said hey you want to
be the kid who plays harry potter and he
was like sure
the conversation went but they uh they
sort of brought me over to him and he
said oh hi nice to meet you and i said
nice to meet you
and i said he said how are you and i
said i'm really i'm quite nervous
i've never been on tv before i don't
really i don't know what i'm going to
talk about and he brilliantly just said
you just tell them you met mr trump
for me that's like that is the that is
the everest of self-confidence
but imagine if i'd just been to you like
when you go on that show just talk about
me
talking about your stuff just looking
like two americans and we're both just
like like sad yeah
that's one thing you're really sad i
know you're all laughing and also the
problem
but also this is kind of the problem
because you do end up talking about him
yeah and
you know we should be talking about the
other people because i know you're
i mean the beauty of the whole thing is
you have to because he just doesn't talk
about himself you feel like you have
yeah
you're a big hillary supporter i know
you've done benefits and
yes yeah yeah yeah i am and but you must
know the white house very well because
you
you seem to go there a lot oh yeah i'm
there all the time
what's the have you played basketball
there or something well i i so
so i was asked by uh president obama
to um everyone hates you already
well it was more or less like you know
just come and
sing something um
but i got there early uh because they
offered to give us a tour of the white
house
again and you had heard these these uh
you know because i've been there with
you yeah no we we still heard the again
yeah yeah guys stay with me yeah
i'd love to see what you've done with
the place yeah yeah so it's different
um wow you've really done a lot with the
kitchen
um no so so you'd heard these rumors
that president obama had his own
basketball court
um to which i had never heard that there
was even a basketball court you never
heard any
you always heard about presidents
playing golf so i was like can i
can i say the basketball court and they
they let me go to the basketball court
and
the balls have president barack obama
stitched it like spalding nba no i
didn't
um i asked for one and they said no
so uh but i was shooting hoops
on the on the court and i was able to
have my manager
film me and i made a half court shot it
only took me like
40 something tries i made a half court
shot and i videotaped it and then
um i there's a picture i think we've got
the picture yeah
so i'm actually showing him
because he you know i mean you
everything you do there
everyone obviously knows
about it i i showed up and he goes i
heard you we're trying to play
basketball on my court
and uh you're the guy who's good though
and i was like
trying okay hold on president
you know and uh and then i showed him
the the
he i mean can we just talk about what an
amazing
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
president
you